well what I love about this episode and
I love all the treat yourself stuff I do
but what always gets me is the way it's
introduced I love when DJ blunts comes
in you know and then he introduces Tom
who comes in and Tom has those treat
yourself cupcakes and then they look
down and look at each other and azizan
wrote are so good in this talking head
they do where they explain the treat
yourself holiday in the various ways
they uh treat themselves and then they
you know they say that that like sing
song it's the best time of the year but
I
I love it I love it in a way that like I
shouldn't love it so much because I
worked on the series yeah like I'm not
like I have nothing to do with the
storyline yeah I mean either it's one of
my favorite moments from the series
entire run they're talking ahead is the
best uh close treat yourself fragrances
treat yourself massages tweak yourself
mimosas treat yourself fine leather
goods
leather goods the way her eyes bulge out
it is
great and it's also a great moment every
so often you get a storyline where two
characters are together who should be
together because they're great together
but then you have a storyline that
brings out the most fun about those
characters yeah and that is treat
yourself with Tom and Donna and what's
great is the choice to throw Ben in to
to gum up the works yeah right who is
the last person you'd expect to be the
third of this group well because also
what and the reason they bring Ben in at
the top of the upper near the top of the
episode Ben is having a meeting with
Jerry and Donna yes and he's being very
um ornery ornery I guess would be the
right word and where is this form Jerry
I see you haven't filled this out in two
and a half years and Jerry's like what
the hell is it and then Tom is like and
we kind of do that at our own pace and
he's like uh-uh like it really yeah was
odd it was a weird thing and you knew
Ben was going through something Donna
clock that right away and so the fact
that she brought him into that mix
again it's the love of the show it's the
love that the characters have for each
other even though Ben was very new
Donna cared for the guy and you know and
all good sitcom characters I have their
own selfish things and if you watch some
of the classic sitcoms you know people
are selfish and stuff but
I think the difference with Parks is as
much as that can happen there's also so
much love and caring for the other
characters so the fact that she brought
him in and Tom was immediately no no
this is our thing but then very quickly
he's like all right yeah right that's
also the fun of it which is that could
have been the entire comedy game which
is no don't bring him in convincing Tom
to bring Ben in on this right this
tradition of theirs that's not what this
is we get that quickly because the fun
is actually going to be Ben being there
the whole time of course
um and and uh Aziz oh my God meet with
these the character names Tom yeah who
is incredibly selfish at most times says
it's the one day a year that I'm selfish
to be selfish
every day you allow yourself for
yourself and then of course Jerry goes
for a cupcake and he slams that down
right away no cupcake for Jerry well you
talked about that moment where Ben is
having attitude with with uh Donna and
Jerry and I love uh where she's like
what's wrong with you do they just
cancel Game of Thrones and you can't
help but respond incredulously he's like
they would never cancel Game of Thrones
it's a crossover hit they're telling
human stories in a fantasy world and I
just was watching that in prep for this
episode with you today and I was like I
wonder what Ben's opinion on the final
season of Game of Thrones would be I
mean oh he'd go on it's controversial I
actually I liked it I don't understand
what all the hate is for but um to me I
I like that but if you if you get me
he's talking about the seasoning for
Ozark I'll go on for a half hour of how
crazed I was so I would love everyone's
different you know if we ever do another
version of the show if we get the
getting back together if we get you if
you all show up again and say like let's
do a sequel series to Parks and Rec if
we don't find out what Ben thought of
the series finale we have a problem we
have a big problem